my understandings and I will be ending
one of these relationships but at the
end of the game the way I understood the
challenge hi I'm Kristen Bell I'm Dax
Shepard and I'm Michael Pena and we're
just here to see who knows that's best
yeah
also we're all in a movie called jet
really fun action comedy I spent like I
don't know probably a year with you and
then just shooting guns run -
motorcycles and I live with him and I
know so I'm very very well intimately
I know but I knew him like 12 hours a
day but I know I'm 12 hours a night so
all right I'm ready to get wild I wrote
the wrong answer I went more specific on
a motor with family Oh Michael he
combined our two answers and it has to
be an emoji you can use so if you're
drawing a penis you can't that's not any
more I'm not I'm not drawing a penis who
knows those grapes
did anyone get it the smiling poop I've
been running this for a few years on
hill there's you that's so weird he only
writes me these one two three 24-karat
magic me so horny by 2 Live Crew I got
to give it to you cos I at least liked
that song but this is your your kind of
the family theme song in a way yes he's
not wrong what can we have spell checks
one two three there is a Jeep there is
it I didn't put it on there I got that
one wrong I forgot yours is mine is a
sloth winning the Baja 1000 I think I
could probably drive a car for upwards
of a week you're gonna go to prison I
got to be honest I think this is closer
motorcycle marathon it's very much in
here what's yours Michael ah haircuts oh
yeah I cut hair did you know that about
me
uh would you write she wrote the answer
I should have written I wrote family I
wrote no one of the family he would
actually bring which is our oldest that
I would and you wrote a speedboat
interesting so I could get back to my
family so I can get back to my family
yes Wow that there's no there's no
coming back to that was food boo
I gotta rethink my answers so I think if
you just look at the numbers she clearly
won but when you when you factor in the
fact that pain you and I just started
dating a year ago I got to give it to
pain I agree right
I agree
[Music]
around